we're told that the first ionization
energy of silver is 7.31 times 10 to the
fifth
joules per mole what is the longest
wavelength of light
that is capable of ionizing an atom of
silver
in the gas phase all right now before i
even ask you to pause and try to do this
on your own
let's just remind ourselves or try to
understand what first ionization energy
even
is this is the energy required to get
the highest energy or outermost
electron to escape from the atom so it's
not just going to go to a higher
energy level it's just going to
completely escape you could view that as
the infinite energy level
and the reason why we're talking about
the longest wavelength of light is
remember the longer the wavelength the
lower the frequency and the lower
the energy so this is saying really
what's the minimum
frequency or the minimum energy that's
associated with the longest wavelength
of light
for an atom an atom of silver
so a couple of things to pay attention
to they're giving us the first
ionization energy in terms of moles
not per atom and then we just have to
remind ourselves
all of our different ways of connecting
wavelength frequency
and energy now given all of this i
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can figure this out
what is the longest wavelength of light
that is capable capable of ionizing an
atom of silver in the gas phase
all right now let's work through this
together so the first thing to do
is try to figure out the first
ionization energy per
atom and so maybe i'll write it like
this so the energy
per atom the first ionization energy per
atom is going to be equal to the
ionization energy
7.31 times 10 to the fifth
joules per mole times
what if we want to figure out per atom
this is per mole
well how many moles are there per atom
well we know that they're this number of
atoms per
mole so if we want to know moles per
atom it's going to be
one mole for
every 6.022 times
10 to the 23rd atoms i could write atoms
here and then that would give us
joules per atom but we're just going to
get the answer in terms of joules
because the moles are going to cancel
out and so
this is going to give us approximately
let's see we have
three significant figures here
7.31 times 10
to the fifth divided by
6.022 times 10
to the 23rd power is equal to
and we have three significant figures
here so 1.21
approximately equal to 1.21 times 10 to
the negative 18.
1.21 times 10 to the negative
18 and the units here are joules this is
joules per atom
so now how do we figure out wavelength
well
as i alluded to we might want to use
these
equations here we know that the speed of
light
is equal to the wavelength of that light
times the frequency of the light this is
the
lowercase greek letter nu this is not a
v right over here
so if we want to solve for wavelength we
just divide both sides by frequency and
so you get the wavelength is equal to
the speed of light
divided by frequency but how do you
figure out frequency
from energy well that's what this top
equation gives us
energy is equal to planck's constant
times frequency
so if you want to solve for frequency
divide both sides by planck's constant
so that top equation can be rewritten as
frequency i'll write it here frequency
is equal to
energy divided by planck's constant and
so we could take
this and substitute it over here
and we would get that our wavelength is
equal to the speed of light
divided by energy
divided by planck's constant or we could
just rewrite this
as being equal to the speed of light
times
planck's constant divided by
trying to keep the colors consistent
divided by energy
well we know what the speed of light is
it is
2.998 or it's approximately 2.998
times 10 to the eighth meters per second
we're going to multiply that times
planck's constant
which is 6.626
times 10 to the negative 34
joule seconds and then we're going to
divide that by the first ionization
energy
per atom which we figured out right over
here so we're going to divide that
that's that this e right over here this
is going to be
we figured it out 1.21
times 10 to the negative 18 joules
now let's make sure all the units work
out so this seconds is going to cancel
out with this seconds
this joules is going to cancel out with
this joules and we're just going to be
left with meters which makes sense
the wavelength can be measured in meters
and so let's just get our calculator out
and calculate what this is going to be
2.998 times
10 to the 8th times
6.626
times 10 to the negative 34
and then i'm gonna divide that by one
point two one times ten
to the negative eighteen i think we
deserve a little bit of a drum roll
that gets us that and let's see
if we have three significant figures is
our smallest amount in this calculation
so we're going to go to these three
right over here and so this is going to
be 1.64 times 10 to the negative
1 2 three four five
six seven so this is going to be
approximately equal to one point six
four times ten to the negative seven
meters and we're done